lawmakers want an EU budget of 160 2.6  billion euros for 2018 they are calling  for more funds for migrations security  fighting youth unemployment and climate  change Parliament wants to see a full  ban on fly for seat base herbicides in  five years time members are also calling  for immediate restrictions on the use of  the substance the 2017 sour of prize  goes to Venezuela's Democratic  opposition and the more than 600  political prisoners the country has seen  serious deterioration in the state of  democracy and human rights in recent  months 11 new elements have been added  to a list of dangerous substances  subject to exposure limits Parliament  wants to better protect workers from  exposure to cancer-causing chemicals in  the workplace there were two point zero  five million posted workers in the EU in  2015 the revised rules aim to ensure  workers get the same pay for the same  work in the same country  [Music]